a menina quiroga e o trabalho há dez
anos mais ou menos com essa função de
mediação são de refugiados e
solicitantes vivo há 14 anos eu era mais
um estudante de comunicação
recém-formada pensando que eu ia fazer
para me destacar naquela multidão de
novos estudantes se formando na época do
boom da web 2.0 em que os reality shows
estavam estourando ea gente tinha também
um boom de novos produtores de
informação competindo com essas três
estudantes recém formados
então na época me pareceu que fazer um
mestrado e tentar me destacar por essa
via talvez você melhor caminho
então eu juntei na época as minhas
economias finais e resolvi que talvez
viajar e aprender o francês e fui para
paris para isso talvez você a melhor
forma de tentar lidar com aqueles
acadêmicos que me prometiam aquele salto
final para essa situação de destaque
tinha várias ilusões ea primeira delas
foi achar que paris
ia me prometer tudo isso e esclarecer
minha vida e foi lido em gum no eu nunca
passei tanto tempo confusa quanto esse
tempo que passei lá primeiro chegando lá
a primeira descoberta que pare já não
era mais esse espaço de glamour não era
mais um espaço de culinária de moda de
intelectuais boêmios resolver os
problemas do mundo em cafés charmosos
filosofando definitivamente não paris a
paris que encontrei outro aparelho seja
nada diversa multicultural em que
pessoas tentarão conciliar o aprendizado
do francês como eu muitas línguas e
sotaques e isso se pra mim parecia muito
interessante essa diversidade que
encontrei
por outro lado de uma coisa muito nova
também acontecendo ali que era uma
tristeza nova uma tristeza nos olhos de
uma população nova
que eram os refugiados da globalização o
refugiado uma vez que tem porque não
pode mais viver porque vive com medo
porque a sua integridade física ou a sua
vida está em risco
são pessoas que fogem de proteger por
motivos de raça religião porque fazem
parte de alguma etnia ou comunga e
defende idéias que não são aceitas pela
maioria ou porque suas opiniões
políticas não fazem sentido e pressão
ameaçadas ou porque ela sofre grave
generalizadas violações de seus direitos
humanos e não sente mais protegida pelo
seu estado
então ela precisa sair e essas que
estavam ali eram essas pessoas erradas e
por que refugiados da globalização era
isso que eu precisava entender pra mim
já não vai fazer sentido nenhum
continuar pensando nas rádios como era o
meu projeto de mestrado
depois que eu encontrei aquela realidade
e aí eu já estava decidido que eu
precisava mudar o meu projeto a e
convencer o meu orientador de que eu não
ia mais estudar reality show pelo menos
não podia estudar daquela forma que eu
estudava bom voltei para o brasil e
tentar entender como é que aquela
realidade das pessoas que estavam ali
tentando se integrar porque paris estava
em chamas tentando integrar essas
pessoas mas essas pessoas também estavam
nos recebiam voltar a seus países
como é que eu ia fazer pra entender que
mundo é esse que produz refugiados ao
mesmo tempo que produz essas
celebridades que mundo é esse que no
mesmo com a mesma força que que estimula
uma liberdade uma liberdade individual
uma liberdade de poder consumir uma
liberdade de massificar globaliza
hábitos e uma liberdade que promete uma
felicidade ao mesmo tempo produz numa
mesma relação de forças refugiados que
não têm acesso a nada disso
é um tratado sobre libertar discutir os
rumos do capitalismo idéia do dessa fala
mas de tentar compartilhar um pouquinho
com vocês os caminhos que eu tive para
construir uma nova hipótese neste
mestrado que era mentira
a hipótese de que o mesmo regime em que
ser uma celebridade é uma promessa de
felicidade para uns é o mesmo regime que
produz nessa outra face da moeda
pessoas que não têm mais condições de
fazer o básico nas suas vidas
se eu voltar um pouquinho
que tenha um celular se não tem assim
uma modelo parecido uma outra marca
vocês sabem que se refugiar que esse
celular marca
talvez conheçam essa relação que para
ser produzida celular e não só o celular
mas o chips
as telas planas para serem produzidos
eles de matérias primas que estão
bastante concentradas em jazidas da
áfrica e que para serem produto
áreas precisam explorar territórios que
são ocupados por pessoas pessoas que
incomodam porque ficam ali são pessoas
que estão ali se não forem retiradas ou
pelo menos suas vidas não forem
diminuídos para que se justifiquem a
saída ou a morte delas
esses minerais não são retirados a gente
começou a se perguntar o que como é que
as empresas de telecomunicação estavam
se virando com essa realidade como é que
elas se comportavam sabendo que
comunidades inteiras estavam sendo
dizimados para que a gente pudesse ter a
liberdade de se transformar de se
desenvolver de fazer updates constantes
de correr atrás das novas tecnologias
porque ninguém quer ficar para trás
ao mesmo tempo em que essas pessoas
estavam ali tendo suas vidas esfacelados
vocês já talvez conheço mas se não 100
eu sugiro colocar essa palavrinha coltan
nos sites de busca
essa palavrinha aí é um mineral que é
muito presente 80% desse mineral está
concentrado nas jazidas do congo eo
congo vive há mais de 20 anos uma guerra
sanguinária em que a população está
sendo dizimada em busca desse mineral
que é o maior responsável mineral muito
poderoso na fabricação desses produtos
esses produtos são só alguns
a gente pode falar dos satélites dos
aviões diversas tecnologias fundamentais
sem as quais a gente não pode mais viver
hoje aqui no brasil gente também tem
ocultam a gente também tem um contando
nessa quantidade
e aí nessa altura do meu mestrado eu já
estava completamente decidida a tentar
criar essa conexão pensar um pouco sobre
isso que mundo é esse das liberdades que
tem tantas faces e o que eu percebi foi
que a gente não vive seguro nem no
brasil nenhum sistema desigual é seguro
porque nenhum sistema desigual com tanto
poder concentrado nas mãos de alguns
permite respeito
e garantia dos direitos desses muitos
outros e quando esses muitos outros são
minimizados porque a gente precisa
explorar esses recursos materiais para
garantir sobrevivência existência a
nossa cabeça em desenvolvimento
se a gente vive assim nenhum regime é
seguro nem regimes democráticos de vale
tão pouco quando as pessoas são trata
como montanhas como rochas que precisam
ser implodidos para que novos automóveis
e novas ruas sejam construídas no
caminho
nenhum gene é seguro a gente tem
contando então a idéia é que qualquer
pessoa pode se tornar refugiado em um
dia
para alguns essa realidade parece mais
próxima a cada vez o turista também já
estava convencido de que não bastaria
defender isso numa sala fechada ou
defender isso numa dissertação tantos
leriam uma dissertação falando dessas
coisas pra mim tava claro que talvez
fosse mais interessante conhecer pessoas
conhecer pessoas pelo menos olhar no
olho dessas pessoas e ver perguntar o
que você precisa
talvez fosse mais útil foi aí que eu
procurei a cáritas e um programa de
acolhimento a refugiados que ela
desenvolve bastante excelência e foi aí
que também entende que tem outras formas
de contribuir e que esse não é um tema
só triste é um tema muito duro mas não é
um tema só triste infelizmente vários
países já estão desenvolvendo leis
mecanismos de proteção para essas
pessoas
infelizmente no brasil a gente tem uma
lei razoável a lei 9474 que de alguma
forma garante assegura a proteção dessas
pessoas e direito delas se integrarem é
e embora cada país tenha ontem a decisão
tem autonomia pra para decidir quanto as
pessoas entram me quantas pessoas podem
ficar sem integradas no brasil pelo
menos a gente já tem uma realidade uma
lei com uma lei que
era antes mas como vocês vão ver também
muito menos pessoas conseguem refúgio do
que pessoas que pedem refúgio a gente
tem mais ou menos 10 mil pessoas
refugiadas reconhecidas assim protegidas
pelo estado brasileiro mais de 80.000
pedem para ser refugiados mas tão só
aguardando a decisão
a gente tem um comitê nacional que julga
cada casa analisa se os motivos que
essas pessoas trazem que defendem alegam
para pedir refúgio se esses motivos eles
são legítimos para garantir essa
proteção esse comitê julga todo mês cada
caso e quando aceita o pedido de refúgio
é importante dizer essas pessoas são
julgadas são aceitas e tem o direito de
estar aqui não é mais um debate não é
mais uma discussão e isso incomoda muita
gente mas essas pessoas têm o direito de
estar aqui
só que elas precisam ser integradas né o
fato é que lei nenhuma garante nenhuma
garante integração né
a gente já sabe por experiência em
outros países países mais bem sucedidos
na integração de migrantes e refugiados
que qualquer sistema só funciona bem
quando toda a sociedade se engajou na
integração de refugiados
pensando na realidade aqui do rio de
janeiro
vamos pensar na realidade do carioca
sabe que qualquer refugiado só se
integra quando o carioca quer não é a
lei 9474 que garante isso se o carioca
não quer e se refugiado que já têm
direito a votar seus filhos na escola e
têm direito a tirar cpf tem direita tira
a carteira de trabalho pouca gente sabe
e se refugiado que pode freqüentar e
acessar o sus e se refugiado
talvez não consiga trabalhar e se ele
não consegue trabalhar ele não é
autônomo e se ele não é autônomo ele não
é integrável a gente não quer a gente
não pode pensar numa integração sem
autonomia certo a gente não pode pensar
que essas pessoas vão ser assistidas nem
por cáritas nem por governos pela vida
toda nem elas querem isso mas para
trabalhar em serem autônomas o carioca
tem que querer
e essa é a realidade empatia é a palavra
chave para a gente entender que só
quando o refúgio é quando um cariocas
não só se interessar mas de fato se
abrir pra abrir uma portinha para e se
refugiado é que a gente vai conseguir
uma interação uma integração realmente
plena e é por isso que a empatia não a
palavra da moda mais uma palavra pra
gente ficar repetindo talvez seja a
maior é o maior aprendizado a gente pode
ter até a nossa situação
né a empatia uma arma de de proteção
para qualquer pessoa por um futuro que a
gente desconhece o então é o que eu
queria compartilhar com vocês é isso que
a gente hoje talvez tenha que repensar
nosso modelo de sucesso que é sucesso
para cada um que é sucesso no mundo
globalizado que prega tanto a superação
individual que cada um tem não só a
liberdade mas o dever de conquistar
sozinho e que pra isso ele talvez
precisa se transformar bastante e esse
regime das celebridades do regime em que
as pessoas garantem seus momentos de
fama e que essa pequena forma talvez
seja a única delas terem conquistas tão
almejados
esse regime de celebridades diz que
brilha quem consegue isso quem se
transforma que corre atrás e supera
sozinho não é isso mas é nesse regime
que a gente tem que pensar quem são os
verdadeiros bem sucedidos quem é que
consegue se transformar tanto se superar
em nome de uma força maior que é simples
desejo irrefreável de viver que são os
desejos dessas pessoas nesses minutos
finais o que eu queria dizer pra vocês é
que pra mim fez muito sentido a 14 anos
tentar olhar para essas pessoas de outra
forma então eu queria deixar para vocês
um convite para pensar em três pontos
primeiro como é que essas pessoas é de
fato tem alguma contribuição podem dar
alguma contribuição à nossa realidade
que valores elas trazem que
contribuições para a nossa sociedade
depois como é que cada um de nós tem a
ver com esse regime que força pessoas a
se deslocarem que hábitos
que movimento os nossos podem se
relacionar com isso tudo que a gente
conversou aqui e por último como é que
cada um de nós pode ser uma peça
fundamental para transformar esse mundo
num mundo que se organiza em bases mais
solidárias e não só mais solidárias mais
realistas porque se as fronteiras estão
se dissipando porque elas precisam se
antecipar
obrigada